well now time for everyone's uh favorite
part of the day maybe and this is where
uh we read some emails from people
asking for advice and various things
what do we got from the Dear Mr Walsh I
have wanted to send an email or comment
for some time but I've always felt I had
nothing good to ask however now I have a
question and have asked friends this and
their opinions bother me and I feel
strongly I am in the right I'm asking to
know if my opinions are Vindicated or if
I'm simply being unreal of my
expectation so here it is I am a
Christian man and have been for the last
eight years I've been in one church this
entire time and over the years I've
found little or no love interest in my
church for the few I have tried they
usually fell flat because of a
difference in opinion on how a courtship
should go I believe that when you're
dating someone you should not be talking
to other potential love interests like
you're at a grocery store I'm not
talking about it in a dating
relationship I'm talking about simply
devoting yourself to the person you wish
to get to know and maybe potentially
date if I'm interested in a woman for
instance I would not talk to other women
with the intention to date them as well
however it seems in today's culture we
women and men Court multiple people at a
time and then choose what appears to be
the best option for themselves I don't
necessarily find this to be wrong but I
feel like if you like someone and are
getting to know them with the intention
of dating them in the future you should
not be getting to know other potential
Shooters at the same time your thoughts
and our advice on this would be
appreciated well
so you're running into the problem this
is uh this is one of the classic
fundamental problems with the modern
dating scene which is that which we've
talked about plenty of times which is
that uh nobody knows what to call
anything nobody knows what to label
anything we've we've uh we've had this
idea that it's it's bad to label we
don't want to put labels on things and
we certainly don't want any idea of like
roles or responsibilities in a
relationship and certainly not in a in a
relationship between a man and a woman
and because we've decided that as a
culture what we end up with is a dating
scene where nobody knows what's going on
like nobody has any idea
they're talking to somebody they don't
know like what are the phases of it
where is this supposed to go what's the
point and if there are uh phases or or
steps in the relationship when do we
reach to the next step and how do we
know we're there and you know like what
what is this exactly so every man is
wondering this and every woman's
wondering this when they're sitting down
to eat with with the with you know the
other person they're both sitting there
thinking like what is this right now and
what's the point of it and our am I is
this a thing is it not a thing these are
all questions that plague I think uh the
modern dating scene they
come into focus in your question
because my answer would be that if
you're actually dating someone
which would I guess be the modern analog
for courtship although I think we should
just get back to calling it that
courtship which is the process of uh you
know when you have found someone that
you want to marry it's the process
leading up to marriage uh or or rather
you know we should say leading up to
engagement uh which then leads to
marriage in courtship you both know
you're with one person and you know that
the intention is to kind of figure out
whether you're going to get married it's
a time of discernment between the two of
you which is what dating allegedly kind
of is supposed to be and if you're in
that stage then yeah you should be
talking to anybody else uh talking to
anybody else in the sense of like you
shouldn't be you know still perusing the
options because this it doesn't work
unless you're committed to that person
and trying to discern and figure out
whether this is going to work as a
marriage but if you're not officially
dating
um and you're still in the phase of just
like trying to meet people and figure
out who you want to date to then lead
hopefully to engagement into marriage
then well of course you're going to talk
to other people
um it's because how else would it work
it's like are you gonna are you gonna
you know you you so let you strike up
one conversation with a woman and you
think there might be something there and
so then you're not gonna talk to anybody
else until you figure out it just
doesn't it doesn't work that way you
know hiring used to be really hard you
uh post your job on multiple sites you
hope the right people see it and then
you wait for them to apply it's similar
to when you're applying for jobs you
search countless places to find a
company that fits best with your skills
and experience and your passions well
now there's a place where you can go
that makes hiring faster and easier it's
called zip recruiter head to
ziprecruiter.com Walsh and try it for
free ziprecruiters matching technology
excels at finding the most qualified
candidates for a wide range of roles see
a candidate you like well you can easily
send them a personal invite so they're
more likely to apply it also gives you a
Competitive Edge against other employers
who may also be interested in that
candidate their user friendly dashboard
makes it easy to filter review and rate
your candidates all from one place you
can see how much easier hiring is with
zip recruiter 4 out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day see for
yourself go to ziprecruiter.com Walsh to
try ZipRecruiter for free again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire you mentioned the word suitors
well like going back to if we're going
to go back to the the old-fashioned way
of doing these things which was better
you had you know uh you had a woman had
suitors and then we landed on one
Arrangement and that leads to courtship
uh but you know there could be multiple
suitors so I guess you kind of have to
figure out what it is first and you have
to be not afraid to put a label on it if
the No like is this officially dating or
not are we official you know people
don't want to ask these things or it's
always awkward too like what do you say
to someone would you be my girlfriend
like it sound it sounds very high school
but uh you've got you have to have some
way of establishing that okay we're
actually dating right now that's what
this is it sounds to me like you're you
know uh you're not establishing that
with with any of these women that you're
talking to if it's not established that
you're officially dating then you can't
be upset at them or talking to other
people you know they no commitment to
you whatsoever all right we'll do uh one
more this is from Liz says Dear Matt and
Sean my husband uh 34 male and I 35
female are recently married we're
wanting to have a baby in the next few
years but we have some fertility
concerns due to our ages and
reproductive health issues I started
birth control at a young age 18 years
old and only recently have come off of
it I was told by my parents doctors and
peers that this is what we're supposed
to do so you can go to college get a job
become established Etc and then later
get married and have kids now it's
looking like I won't be able to have
kids in the future and wanted to know
your thoughts on adoption and fostering
as much as we really want to have our
own biological child that may not be an
option for us is adoption or fostering a
child worth pursuing my husband and I
are by no means wealthy and we both must
work full-time any advice you could give
would be greatly appreciated thanks so
much and love listening to your show
yeah this is uh it's important that
people hear your story too because
there's many stories like this young
women sold this story about birth
control the magic pill it solves all
your problems and you know it's like
there's no trade-offs at all just take
the pill you don't have babies and then
because it's it's you're too it's too
early and you haven't established
yourself and then down the line whenever
you want to have kids you can have kids
but what it turns out that it's not
always that easy and that there are it
ends up being a trade-off in so many
cases and it's a tragedy too because
it's a trade-off that uh that you might
not understand was a trade-off until
until it becomes apparent so I mean
hopefully you know and there are if you
have uh fertility issues and all the
rest of it I'm sure you're looking into
you know you're talking to doctors and
everything
um so hopefully for you it you know
it'll still turn out that you can
um that you can conceive a child but if
you can't what about the option of
adoption and fostering Well I obviously
can't
tell you whether that's the right option
for your family but it's absolutely
something worth uh investigating and
certainly talking about and praying
about adoption is a is a beautiful
vocation and it's it's something that's
very much needed you know if you're the
adopted parent of a child then you are
the parent if you're an adopted mother
you are the mother and you know it's
just as much as as uh if you conceive
the child yourself so yeah I would
absolutely
think about that and and uh and pray
about it and you know have a period of
discerning about that as well you know
I've said before I've said many times
that I think every married couple is
called to
Parenthood you know every woman is
called to be a mother every Ever every
man's called to be a father
and in many cases that is going to mean
like in the biological sense of
conceiving a child but not in every case
there are other ways of um of being a
mother and of being a father and of
course one of the most obvious ways is
through adoption so uh good questions
there and we will leave it there for
today talk to you tomorrow
[Music]
if the love is the truth